credit monitoring company Equifax is
dealing with growing fallout this
morning over its massive data breach the
personal data of 143 million Americans
was exposed this summer that information
includes Social Security numbers
addresses and credit card data
Equifax faced backlash for initially
charging protection fees to those who
tried to freeze their credit files but
the company said on Twitter Monday it
would waive all security freeze fees for
the next 30 days CBS News business
analyst Jill Schlesinger is here with
the steps consumers can take right now
good morning alright first how can you
find out if your informations been
compromised go to the website Equifax
security dot 2017 dot-com just go there
I know you've been done trusting the
information but you must take this first
step you're gonna put in the last six
digits of your social and your last name
you're gonna press a button it's going
to say you either were or we're not
affected the next step from that point
is that you will automatically be taken
to a place where you can get that
protection for one year from Equifax but
that's not where you stop because please
know just those two steps will not
protect you going fo I have no account
with Equifax and never dealt with
Equifax should I still be worried yes
you should because if you've ever
actually applied for credit in any way
shape or form this is data that's out
there with Equifax Experian and
TransUnion okay if you have been exposed
what specific steps should you take
so next step is you can put a free fraud
alert it's a 90 day process where you
are essentially saying to the companies
if something is looking like someone's
looking at my file let me know and you
have to do that with one of these
companies not each one of them you'll
notice that we've always talked about
Equifax Experian TransUnion as the big
three there's another one called in of s
which you should put on the list notify
one of them that will automatically
actually indicate to the others that
there is now a free fraud alert on your
file again ninety days only but what's
really important after that that's what
step one step two is you can take a much
more draconian measure and that is
called a credit freeze this is
incredibly important this is the only
way to lock
down your file the reason is that anyone
who actually wants to establish credit
in your name will be thwarted at that
process big caveat gang if you yourself
need credit you have to unfinish the
file with each of the companies I've
heard you say it's not a matter of if
your credit is compromised it's a matter
of when yeah how are we supposed to do
with that information so I think what we
have to do is take an abundance of
caution here we have a credit incident
that they call it we hundred forty three
million Americans that is more than half
of us so you've got a 50/50 shot that
you've been exposed you want to be as
safe as you can so again the alert the
freeze but you want to be careful about
how you manage your information you
don't want to over share on social media
you want to go to annualcreditreport.com
every single year get that free credit
report make sure no one is poking around
and doing stuff and be sure to check
your credit card statements in the
months ahead
this information will live in the dark
web for perhaps years to come so very
careful here Charlie's got out right and
all in all he's got good information
thank you Joe Thank You dill